there's this massive class of
professional workers who you know work
in banking or consulting or doctors or
whatever it is where you ask like why
are you working so hard why are you
doing this and their answer is that they
have the money to do XYZ so that I can
retire in Greece or so that I can like
buy a Vineyard and go retire on this
Vineyard you know in Napa or whatever it
is and the vast majority of them don't
do it The Wall Street Journal released a
breakdown of how people spend their time
in retirement and it was horrifying
because it was like four and a half
hours a day of watching TV it was one of
the things on the list if you think that
you're doing all of this work today
because you're gonna have this glamorous
retirement living on the beach and you
know sipping pina coladas you're kidding
yourself what you're gonna end up doing
is sitting around and watching
television because you're going to be 70
and you're not going to have the energy
and the physical health to go do all
those things probably you're gonna have
to be stuck at home